foreign
killings in France I've shown that there
is an issue with the police as an
institution
[Music]
we have like you know numbers that show
about police killings above all are
actually 90 of the time directed by
people of color so it must be North
African people black people in France
but not only
[Music]
in the slow it's written it's giving a
list of situation in which like the cops
can open fire without being afraid or
scared of being prosecuted in fact and
this is also this is why we call it
license to Kill because it's explaining
and if you are and this is this this
situation you can just open fire and you
will be covered you will be protected
and you will not be prosecuted
[Music]
all right